hello we're glad you joined us for
today's webinar mass spectometry
in the clinical laboratory challenges
and opportunities I am Christina mahalik
of lappers and I will be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by laberd's believing
scientific social networking websites
and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaboration in learning this webinar
is made possible by an open educational
grant from Agilent Technologies let's
get started you can post questions to
the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left is a
presentation window questions will be
answered via email after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing a presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left this
is an educational webinar ACEF offers
free continuing education credit after
the webinar is over please click on the
C e button located at the bottom left
hand corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credit
it is now my pleasure
super this today's speaker dr. William
Clark from Johns Hopkins School of
Medicine dr. Clark is an associate
professor of pathology at the Johns
Hopkins University School of Medicine
his research focuses on the development
of analytical methods for drug analysis
clinical mask
the tree and devices for point-of-care
testing dr. Clark serves as the director
of clinical toxicology as well as
critical and point-of-care testing
program at the John Hopkins hospitals
his current team projects include
quality of screening for antiretroviral
drugs and substances of abuse in various
HIV prevention clinical trials
development and validation of mass
spectometry methods for clinical
analysis and development of clinical
assays for use on microfluidic platform
dr. Clark received his BS in chemistry
from the University of Nebraska at
Kearney and his PhD in analytical
chemistry from the University of
Nebraska Lincoln as well as an MBA from
the Carey School of Business at Johns
Hopkins University he completed a
postdoctoral fellowship in clinical
chemistry at the John Hopkins School of
Medicine dr. Clark will now begin his
presentation hello so today I'd like to
talk to you a little bit about the use
of mass spectrometry in clinical
laboratories we'll discuss some of the
challenges to implementing this
technology and then some of the places
where I think there are really good
opportunities for this to have an impact
on laboratory medicine before I get
started I do need to make some
disclosures so on this slide I do have
disclosures to make regarding my
research support as well as some
Advisory Board relationships the ones
most pertinent today to today's lecture
would need those with thermo Fisher and
shimasu for whom I both do sponsored
research and also have an advisory
relationship so when we think about the
Clinical Laboratory there are a wide
variety of technologies that can be
implemented starting from it if you look
at the upper right-hand corner of the
slide we have something simple like a
laminar flow amino acid
a dipstick for drug testing we can have
handheld devices and all the way to the
high-throughput clinical analyzers and
see in the upper left-hand corner of the
slide where these things fit together is
sort of there's a continuum there and
many medical technologists and clinical
lab staff are quite familiar with these
technologies but we have the more
complex technologies we'll see on the
bottom row of the slide where we have
chromatography mass spectrometry or a
gas chromatograph there and those are
used more for niche analyses and they're
not as widely used so when we want to
talk about maybe maybe why not is so
when we think about mexicana tree we
tend to think about it it really depends
on your perspective and I think that
those that are coming out of a medical
technology training program or a CLS
training program they may have a very
different viewpoint or a different level
of familiarity with mass spectrometry
relative to say a laboratory director
that's just come out of a training
program or a forensic toxicology
director or something like that so how a
mess spectrometer is used can vary
depending on your background and we want
to talk a little bit about how it's
getting into the the clinical laboratory
environment well so we'll start a little
bit getting into the benefits and
challenges for clinical mass
spectrometry as a technology and we'll
talk about the opportunities in the
second half of the discussion today so
if you think about until recently mass
spectrometry was really used in a very
narrow focus in clinical testing the
mass spectrometry was used in a say
inborn errors of metabolism screening it
was used for toxicology confirmation we
may use it in conjunction with gas
chromatography for some select
toxicology testing or perhaps if you're
a regional reference laboratory you may
do some heavy metal analysis with icd-9
spectrometry but by and large those
applications until the last 10 or 12
years weren't work really widespread
they were very focused in barn
and then what would really open the door
for my perspective is the the case of
the drug czar role in this which is a
powerful immunosuppressive drug used in
transplantation that when it came on to
the market it was beginning to be used
by clinicians there was no commercial
assay for drug level monitoring and this
is very important immunosuppression
therapy it's important to avoid the
toxicity from the drug as well as making
sure that patients get into the optimal
immunosuppressive brain waves quickly so
that they can avoid acute rejection
which can lead to chronic rejection down
the line and ultimately even a loss of
organs so therapeutic monitoring and
immunosuppressive therapy is is very
very important and so in the absence of
a commercial assay LC mass spectrometry
was used in selected transplant centers
around me around the US and around the
world and but that's a pretty expensive
solution to what was at the time a low
volume drug used in transplantation and
so those centers that had mass
spectrometry for measuring sirolimus
they felt that well if we're going to
have this technology even though there
are metal assets available they're quite
expensive and so perhaps we would be
better served by moving all of our
immunosuppressive drugs into being
measured by LC mass spectrometry and so
that's where we did so to Cronus which
was the highest volume it still is in
terms of therapeutic drug monitoring for
immunosuppressants that was moved into
the on to the lcms instruments as well
as cyclosporine and microphone counsel
but even doing that that restricts a
little bit the application of this
technology as it really has limited his
support of transplant patients there are
some other selected clinical
applications but for the most part it's
transplant patients and so then there
had to make an assessment where where we
would have and people started to think
about well what are some other
applications we can use them and is
those of us that are focused on
therapeutic drug monitoring we know that
there are very few
new commercial assays available for
doing the therapeutic drug monitoring
and so as we have this technology for
immunosuppressive drugs we start to look
at other applications in there to drug
monitoring such as an acquittal and the
other tricyclic antidepressants we think
about bora comas all or post accountants
all and we think of a drug like
clozapine which is important for an
antipsychotics or maybe we spare them
and so nowadays we would think that that
LC mass spectrometry is a very important
tool for therapeutic drug monitoring and
then the first I would say really high
volume applications this would be
vitamin D as people were trying to
differentiate between vitamin 2 d2 and
vitamin d3 and there was a scientific
literature growing while it may be
controversial but many folks think that
measuring vitamin D and blood is a
useful laboratory test and that is
something that was used significally an
amino acid was not able to differentiate
between the different forms of vitamin D
and typically they're not sensitive
enough to detect the biologically active
metabolite the one the 125 divided
indeed and so from that perspective
people continue to use mass spectrometry
for nutritional analysis so now we have
therapeutic drug monitoring applications
and nutrition applications and then
folks that get into the clinical
toxicology there was some appeal to
using liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry as opposed to a gas
chromatography because no derivatives
ation is necessary and you could
potentially measure the glue dried
metabolites directly as opposed to
having to do an enzymatic or heat our
acid base hydrolysis so we think see
comments like cocaine or ecstasy or THC
I see a typo even in my slide now but
for marijuana analysis and so people
start to use this for first definitive
method screening or to do confirmatory
testing and so that was another
application and then finally people
started to look into analytes for which
there were commercial athletes but
perhaps they weren't very good at
something like ester
where there are look there are problems
with lack of harmonization between
different vendors or something like free
testosterone or free thyroid hormones t4
and t3 and so now we have a very broad
range of potential applications for mass
spectrometry and then with the advent of
proteomics where people are starting to
do things like peptide peptide
pull-downs with antibodies and they're
measuring using it using a mass
spectrometer as the detector rather than
using rather than using another a second
antibody labeled antibody is the
detector and there are some benefits to
using antibodies coupled with mass
spectrometry is meh' spectrometry in
that we could perhaps capture a broad
range of proteins like albumin and then
look at post translational modifications
or hemoglobin or something of that
nature there are now reference
laboratories offering thyroid globulin
or plasma renin activity based on mass
spectrometry assonance and and so in
that perspective there'll there are a
wide range of applications and the
question is what where does it benefit
what problem does it solve and how can
we get there so when we think about
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
we're really thinking about three
different types of detectors we won't
get into those detectors today we're
thinking about a triple quadrupole there
are many vendors that have these types
of triple quadrupole for simple
quantification and then to get into the
toxicology applications often times or
proteomics either a time of flight or
Orbitrap analyzer for high resolution
mass spectrometry is a desire but when
we move into these regardless of the
mass analyzer that selected the question
really is what's driving that decision
what's the benefit perceived or real
that makes people want to move into
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
and so one of the big drivers is cost
and flexibility so if we start with cost
we think of the the reagent cost for it
for an amino acid
sometimes particularly if it's low
volume the cost per sample analysis
whether it's control or a calibrator or
a clinical specimen can be quite high
perhaps even 10 or 20 dollars per
specimen whereas with on a per sample
basis the mass spectrometry uses some
organic reagents it uses a pro
photographer column which is which is
can be used for 500 or 1,000 or
sometimes even 2,000 injections and so
the cost per sample can be spread out
over those those those column cost and
so it cost per sample is quite low for
lc/ms spectrometer from a reagent
perspective now certainly there is a
high capital cost that goes along with
that and there can be some other
associated constant we'll talk about
down the line but but on a per sample
cost for reagent certainly lc/ms is
quite low and when we think about the
flexibility which is you know to develop
an amino acid that can be quite
time-consuming we consider having to
identify the proper epitope to
characterize interferences and cross
reactivity to generate that it can take
anywhere from you know 18 months to 2
years to come up with a validated
immunoassay and even maybe three to five
years for that to include the FDA and
become commercially available certainly
there may be exceptions to that but as a
rule it's a good private three or five
year process I would guess to get an FDA
cleared commercial amino essay whereas
with a lab develop tasks using lcms
spectrometry in three to six months you
can have a fully developed validated
acid ready to go and insufficient and
appropriate for clinical use you can
developing these things rapidly and it
can be applied to a wide range of
compounds but there are some technology
barriers that have to be taken into
account
certainly the robotics are not as mature
in the NBL CMS in terms of obviously
there are a complex instrument but they
don't have the
we have automation that we're used to
seeing in the clinical laboratory in
terms of interaction and the amount
personnel that it takes to interact with
the instrument and so they're relatively
low throughput a fast mass spectrometry
immunoassay can be mass spectrometry
assay in the clinical lab often is 15 to
20 samples per hour as opposed to 1 to
200 samples per hour and regular
clinical analyzers so there's a time
constraint for these that it's really
limited for high-volume an alliance
there's a barrier for the clinical lab
scientists they're not familiar with the
instrumentation so there's a natural
apprehension for this week epically
they'll trade all the clinical lab
scientists to do this it's a very narrow
part of the work force that we allow to
work on the instrument
none of the mass spectrometers have
barcode meters or oftentimes with very
few exceptions there's not integrated
automation so there's offline batch
processing then there's a transferal to
a specimen rack or a plate that has to
go on to the auto sampler for mass
spectrometry and that allows
opportunities for specimen switches or
transcription errors and so it's really
for all the techno technology advances
in the analyzing part of it in the
automation workflow part of it it's very
rudimentary in and it is it is a real
challenge and and that's a big barrier
to the work into the interlude clinical
work space and then there's the total
cost of ownership so while the per
sample cost is quite low there still are
the service cost and the increased
attention and labor that will go on with
it if you have to have if there's not
very much walk away time I think that's
important to consider and then last is
this idea of variability and not can
standardize ation so we think about mass
spectrometry as being a much more
analytically robust technology but it
doesn't have the same level of
and traceability or comparability to
existing methods and so because we've
lab develop tests at least at the
current time don't go through the FDA
process labs that develop don't always
match we don't get those same answers
and we have a case example here and that
would be we're thinking about let's talk
about using mass spectrometry for
therapeutic drug monitoring so if we
think about the acceptability criteria
for many of the monitored drugs that
acceptability criteria is if it's not a
percentages it's about three standard
deviations well well let's think about
what that means right what does three
standard deviations mean it means that
even though we're doing external
proficiency testing that doesn't mean
our methods match in fact just by
definition as we look at the
distribution almost all of the results
are going to follow the three standard
deviations depending on the number of
labs that are conforming to testing and
so we use an example of the proficiency
test that we have used several years ago
which is this idea of looking at the
distribution so you what you what you'll
notice in this meatus press efficiently
testing we were using this some time ago
because the targets were published and
what you'll see here is that the
distribution is ranging from 11 all the
way up to 17 nanograms per ml and it
looks like quite a wide spread of those
and we see these three samples here and
each of these samples are almost all of
the lavatories you'll see that there are
a hundred and twenty-eight laboratories
and in the top 126 laboratories past
proficiency testing so all the two and
in the bottom two panels all but one
counts proficiency testing and this is
not uncommon so just like we said if the
criteria is within three standard
deviations
almost everyone consoles but we think
about medical decisions and we know as
clinical auditoriums or analytical
chemists that if we make multiple
measurements on the same specimen we
have some variability so even if we have
an accurate measure with the with the
mean we still have some variability so
we know we're around
the bullseye but we're not always
hitting the bull's eye every time
unfortunately our customers or the
people that we support often expect that
everything every measurement we get is
exactly 100% true with no error involved
and so that's a challenge we need to
think carefully you know just because
we're using mass spectrometry doesn't
mean that it's automatically going to be
in that second scenario we're on the
bull's eye every time and so we need to
really be vigilant about how we're doing
so let's take it back to the example of
proficiency testing so we think about
two chromis that's that's the dragon and
Christy testing example and we see the
therapeutic target is published at five
to 15 anagrams per mil sometimes it's
even five to twenty milligrams per mil
and when we do a proficiency testing
we're compared to the peer mean and
that's not always the truth right and
also it's important to note that the
actual targets for transplantation are
not five that's 15 and five to twenty
they're often narrower and so I embarked
on an exercise to see really what that
looks like in the context of our
proficiency testers so we go back to
that to that distribution now look at
this in the context of a particular
medical decision and here what we're
looking at is if it's a hypothetical
exercise but let's say we're looking at
this and a heart transplant patient
who's just less than three months out
from transplantation so if you speak to
a transplant pharmacist they would say
well our target is 12 and our acceptable
range is between 10 and 50 now if you
look at those results you'd see the
target concentration of what is known to
be spiked in the sample as 18 in other
words it's above the range but if you
look at the distribution meaning you'll
see that the mean of this distribution
is within the range so that would mean
that no dose adjustment would be needed
as opposed to the truth which would
require in dose adjustment and we would
say if you are thinking about not
comparison to the mean but comparison to
the medical decision you can see that
everyone quote unquote fails probably
except for the people that really fail
because the people that really fail if I
can pull my tool up here
you'll see the people that actually fail
are right here and they're above 17 but
the target is 18 so you'll see there
that what's really going on is that the
people that have the higher level
outside of the three standard deviations
were likely we don't know what those
numbers are because they were reported
as greater than three standard
deviations they could have been at
thirty and then of course they would not
be good to the medical decision point
either but what we're saying is then
certainly all the people that passed
we're not having the same medical
decision that would be dictated based on
the target concentration so we take this
a step further we'll go in the other
direction so the bottom samples here
we'll look at and we'll see that in
we're doing a hypothetical with lung
transplantation from three to twelve
months out here the target range by the
pharmacist will be eight to twelve
nanograms familiar and what we would see
here is that an individual lab say even
my lab we that the target is ten and
that's right within the range but the
method mean is eight being here which is
about the midpoint it's a little less
than than the units on the edge of the
of the medical decision range but my lab
was solved here so even though we passed
proficiency testing comparison to our
peers everyone using LC mass
spectrometry we actually would fail well
attempt to the medical decision point
meaning we needed to take a good look at
our method and do better and so this is
something that's inherent again I give
this point not to illustrate problems
with proficiency testing or problems
with my lab in general but what I'm
showing is that it's not just a foregone
conclusion that by using chromatography
mass spectrometry you are have certainly
solved all your laboratory problems it's
important to stay vigilant and do the
things that you know you can do all
right
so I say that not to doubt I speak a bit
on mass spectrometry we use it we have a
large university mass spectrometry
laboratory as well as using it
Hospital and so those are challenges
that must be met and we have research
ongoing for that but you know i think i
think that in spite of some of those
challenges there really are a lot of
emerging opportunities for clinical mass
spectrometry and so i'd like to spend
the next few minutes touching on some of
these opportunities and so the first
thing we'll show here is this is use of
a multi-channel chromatography system so
when we talk about limited throughput
we're really thinking from the
perspective we're really thinking from
the perspective of a single channel
chromatography system and really more
standard approaches to quantification
and if we look at something here we
would say high-throughput quantification
we have in our university laboratory a
method for screening antiretroviral
drugs for HIV prevention studies and
it's a four channel chromatography
system where we we're preparing one
sample while we'll analyze another one
so everything is staggered and we're
able to look at a large number of drugs
in in about two minutes but we thought
well gosh it if we're doing that for 20
drugs what if we were looking at just
one drug can we do a really high
throughput quantification so in this
case we're using a guard column and
we're using multi channel chromatography
and what we find is that I want to point
this out the total analysis time here is
30 seconds point five minutes and so we
could get a peak every point five
minutes or now that means we're going to
get close to a hundred samples an hour
that would be maximum of 120 samples per
hour right and we did this with redshift
and we do this very rapidly I would say
we do this development within two days
and what we see is we're able to
generate a calibration curve we did
preliminary precision we were at less
than 4% of at both 100 nanograms per ml
and 375 milligrams per mil and this
allows us to run a full calibration
curve and do things quickly
and get a robust analysis this is
something we'll pursue a little bit more
in the future but that really would take
care of it doesn't solve the technology
barrier in terms of familiarity with the
technology but it does address some of
the throughput and there are some other
studies ongoing where we look at engage
it engagement about alternate ways of
calibrating can we do can we eliminate
calibration curves and in a sense or at
least calibrate less frequently doing
multiplex analyses is another and
another they increase throughput but but
certainly using a multi-channel
chromatographic system is going to do
that and so I for those of you that are
interested in some of the technical
details what we're really doing is the
data dependent acquisition where we're
fragmenting if we get above a certain
threshold and this chromatographic
method we use for antiretrovirals like
they said it's two minutes for 20
compounds but we're just as easily able
to do to program the method to get this
we switch columns about every 30 to 40
seconds and we get one two three product
ions per compound now another
opportunity for mass spectrometry is
related to the dried blood spots now
dried blood spots tables have been used
for many years and pharmaceutical
studies and so and the way business
status for samples are metered on to
filter paper cards and then that's tried
and there defecated and stored and
grabbed multiple spots and then those
are shipped to the testing laboratory
where punches will take it from the
dried blood spot and to be suspended in
solvent and the resulting solution after
resuspension and processing is given for
analysis bio cement spectrometry now
what I just described does not sound
like really low throughput right but why
do we want to do that then well the idea
of course is that if you are just
putting a little spot of blood on a
piece of filter paper that maybe you can
do less invasive say simple click less
invasive sample collecting maybe you can
do capillary fingerstick samples or heel
sticks for babies which
already do foreign-born air screening
but could you use those dried blood
spots for inboard air or newborn
screening could you use those for other
types of analyses and would that be a
bridge to point-of-care testing I
managed the chroma tree or certainly
point-of-care you know near patient
let's put it that way near patient
sampling and if you're using smaller
sample lines could you make do collect
more time points because you're not
worried about taking too much blood and
then certainly there's also the
application in animal studies with
clinical research where you don't have
to necessarily sacrifice the animal and
that can be done social as well so it
still doesn't address the throughput it
allows for some micro sampling but I
think that there are some techniques
that that will allow us to even address
the throughput issue as well so if we
think about our steps for analysis we
start really if we're starting in the
upper left hand corner what we do is we
do a sample collection and that means we
obtain the to the blood and that to
below has to be sent refused to remove
the cellular component and then from
that we transfer to a processing to
where we ultimately remove protein or do
some at least some sort of dilution and
eccentric views to remove the sediment
from the sample and then transfer
oftentimes again to another sample vial
or sample plate and then we do analysis
and this this process is why we have to
do we have to do batch analysis we can't
do it any other way and that limits our
throughput and how fast we can turn on
test results and sometimes the utility
of the testimony but what if we could
instead of doing all of these different
steps my instead of getting each of
these steps what if we could just go
straight from collection to analysis and
I think there are a couple of different
technologies or there are multiple
technologies these are two that we we're
starting to explore in our laboratory I
think may be interesting to do that and
what would be to do online tried blood
spot analysis and so this is a slide
given courtesy of spar : and it's an
automatic automated dried blood spot
analyzer soon
instead of doing a punch out of the
actually doing a punch out of the card
what you're able to just take that card
and with an automated sampler you're
able to clamp the card you pull back out
our arrows we clamp the card here in an
automated way and then we slow mobile
phase directly through the slide and
then we take that and you'll see here we
have the middle of the dried blood spot
has been completed and that's been
captured on a guard column or some sort
of online so today's extraction
cartridge then that's captured while
much of the remnants go to waste and
then we're able to elute from our
capture column onto our analytical
column and then we're able to generate
results so we could go straight from
collection right to analysis and that
could help us with some of the some of
the processing steps but what would be
important for that would be having some
ability both from the hardware
perspective but also software to be able
to recognize let's see if I can move
this a little bit so what I'm talking
about is the barcode here so that
barcode if it can be programmed to tell
the autosampler what tests were ordered
right so you'd have a specific okay this
is my new a trip Toulon card and it
would read that barcode and it could say
yes this is a barcode it's an or triplet
card and we know that this is the
specimen identifier is embedded in wot
then that could get you closer to a rate
of access or a highly automated high
group put analyzer the challenge of
course is that none of the odds samplers
can do that right now
certainly that we're not doing that in
our laboratory but that you can see a
path toward that as long as the
technology matures another way to do
this would be paper spread mass
spectrometry and so this is from a
couple different angles this was a the
cartridges for paper spray can be found
here this is work that came out of the
cooks lab at Purdue and now what you'll
see is that these cartridges can be
impregnated with drive
blood or tried to your honor perhaps
even a cellular sample and then they're
loaded into the cartridge which will
then feed the the paper spray ionization
mechanism so when we think about what
that looks like here's a better
depiction of what the paper spray is
actually doing so here what we find is
that the sample is applied to the paper
I guess there was an already an arrow
there you didn't need my arrow the paper
is applied to the sample applied to the
paper then at that time both a solvent
and high voltage in this particular sign
so we have a solvent we have high
voltage is applied and that generates a
spray you'll see this here in the
micrograph in the lower left hand corner
you can see that's an actual spray
coming out the tip of the paper and in
this publication references at the
bottom of the slide you'll see that they
were able to get a mass spectrum for
engine tension one off of a filter paper
so this could be a low cost way right
again at the point of collection you
could pre impregnate the paper with
internal standard or you could add it in
after the fact or in the applying buffer
there are lots of different ways you can
think about getting the internal
standard onto the onto the paper but you
could get a genuine quantitative
analysis as long as there is some level
of automation built in if there is a
buck code reader mechanism in which to
feed that information in terms of what
experimental parameter should be but
most a commoner if you can do that you
could get to again a direct from
collection to analyzer
pathway so that's pretty exciting
another area that I think is really
exciting is this idea of doing Titian
imaging so a lot of what we've talked
about before is in the clinical
chemistry core laboratory type of
analysis and again you know moving on
we're going to talk a little bit about
anatomic pathology there's a whole
series of applications around Medical
Microbiology that we won't touch on
today but the exciting part about the
that mass spectrometry is that you're
able to use whether you're using and if
you're using desi shown here or using
some sort of a flow probe technology or
you're using multi imaging like
especially with you know pioneer bases
is which cap really and others and if
you're able to if you're able to
generate this you can get a lot of
biochemical information that's
complementary to some of the staining
infant information mythologist use so we
think about anatomic pathology it's
dominated by the ability diesel
microscopy I don't know how to use a
microscope I can barely work the knobs I
can never get it and focus the way I
want it and maybe that's just because I
have political area I don't I don't know
but I know that you know pathologists
are very good with the microscope and
there are well-documented protocols for
staining and immunity of chemistry and
and this is really the way that folks do
this but you're still dependent on what
can be viewed viewed by the eyeball or a
fluorescence microscope we also know
that in biomarker discovery tissue
analysis correlated with a circulating
fluid like blood this is vital because
you know ultimately you don't want to
have to identify up front on biopsy we
would like to be able to do screening in
blood you can identify an appropriate
biomarker so this idea of direct
analysis of Titian may actually
transpose these issues and modeling a
spectrometry conducting is the current
standard and they're able to generate
these there are some time issues but
certainly they can get very high
resolution images but the turnaround
time is you submitting it from
limitation so we're not an expert in the
with the Molly imaging but certainly we
are taking a look at in conjunction I
have a collaboration with a pathologist
here and what we do is we're looking at
something like dancing so desi in this
case is the surface desorption technique
where the electrospray goes directly to
the cells and tissue on the slide and
then that the secondary spray is is
directed into the master
and this allows us to extract the
biochemical analyze from the tissue and
then spray them in the medicine analyzer
it's okay the reason the distance of
interest because we look at this so what
you're seeing right now is a finding
elaborate of a kidney tumor that's
illegal clear cell carcinoma and in this
what we have is they've done the fine
needle aspirate and the end the
dissection and what you'll see on the
left is a oil read of stain and the red
pull my pointer here the the web
vesicles that's where the lipids are so
that's where you have fatty tissue and
to do an oil rid of stain it requires a
special preservative they've given it
advance rate for cellular integrity now
if you look over in the right hand thing
this is a row and ASCII Romanowski stain
and and in this one it's the reason it's
called a clear cell carcinoma is that
you're actually washing away the
cellular component is because it's if
there's an ethanol wash which gets rid
of the lipids and in this case the blue
things are basic the anything red on the
slide is acidic and then the clear
places here where the fat used to be
that's been washed away and so this is
this is some unpublished data from our
laboratory and then we took this type of
a preparation and we analyze it using
dense mass spectrometry and what my
colleague Matthew Olson was able to show
is he was able to show in this case what
you're looking at is we lost the top but
that's benign tissue here here what
we'll find is clear so weíll carcinoma
in the second line and the third line is
benign peri wheedle adipose tissue so in
looking at the Atlas tissue and then the
last one is looking at blood so we're
trying to make sure that if we find any
differences they're really due to the
real cell carcinoma and not due to other
tissue differences around around where
the sample was taken and what we find is
if you look in these two spots you'll
see that we found some lipid Peaks
corresponding to the clear cell renal
cell carcinoma that we don't find and
the other types of tissue and so this is
this was really good but it was
challenging to optimize because we have
the variability of the sample time a
fine needle aspirate and we also have
the variability in the desert so we
moved to a similar technology called the
flow probe and in this one what we have
is is you have liquid that is deposited
onto the sample and then what though is
it
liquids the Tom's own sample but it's
drawn back up through the straw or the
two and then it's converted into a spray
source and you get an electrospray
ionisation and that goes to the mass
spectrometer and on the left is an
actual photograph of the open flow probe
relative to a target so it's greatly
enlarged this business work that was
Matthew published in just last year in
journal American society some pathology
in Belize but anyway so what we wanted
to do is is we want to think about
what's what are the capabilities with
technology and really the driver for
this why are we just doing mobius
already showed to be the you know sort
of much the emphasis is done there it's
a very mature field dr. Conoley and
others have done a lot of really good
work there so why would we why are we
playing around with these other
techniques I think one of the biggest
ones is that it maintains the cellular
integrity not so important for a chemist
necessarily but for a pathologist that's
vital because they want to be able to
look at the tissue after they've
analyzed about mass spectrometry and so
when we look at the slides here we see
on the left hand side we see something
that's been air-dried and on the right
hand side we see a cellular preparation
that has been slow probed and analyzed
by mass spectrometry and the differences
are minimal even for this manuscript
they were shown to seven
psychopathologies and six of the saito
pathologists actually preferred this
image on the right which had already
been analyzed by mass spectrometry and
1/7 picked the slide the image on the
left and that was actually from a coin
flipped they had trouble differentiating
between the two so from from a
morphology perspective they it still
maintains the integrity so you can look
at the cells and makes us
in addition to having two biochemical
information and that's really important
because per mod the imaging you use it's
a destructive technique you're
destroying the tissue now you can get
consecutive slices of the tissue but
it's not exactly the same I don't want
to oversell the difference but I think
that there's a benefit to being able to
interrogate the same sample multiple
times and also still be able to look at
it under a microscope and then correlate
all those observations both visual and
biochemical and I think that's that's
something that we're excited to pursue
in the future and so here's an example
this is a paper that's in submission and
again you'll see it it's classification
what we find that we're able to identify
lipids directly from the tissue we're
using high resolution mass spectrometry
to identify specifically in those cases
phosphatidylcholine and Buster choline
and then we look at the losses so that
we can figure out what's what's going on
in the intubation
now when we think about mom the imaging
this is this is another important
technology of accept right now it's the
gold standard in it and because it's not
doing it's not doing scanning or
anything else its destructive true but
you can get multiple types of images
from the same analysis so there I would
view a lot of these things with
complementary not necessarily
competitive and so here you would get a
frozen section of the tissue and then
you're able to and there's a whole lot
of development work and optimization in
the works that's gone on in the
epicenter of Vanderbilt and other places
but in fact I highly recommend you
you're visiting this this website that
they have set up for their Center and
they'll get a frozen section they'll
apply that to a slide or make a target
and then they're able to put matrix and
then they're able to raster the laser at
high resolution and at each step of the
laser they're able to get multiple
images because all of the ions are
captured so that each position they know
what's coming up and what's lying and
then they're able to take that
information and decom move it in a way
that they get multiple overlaid images
of what they found in
and so here's an example from same group
and experimental dermatology and you'll
see they looked at the same sample where
they rascal plays when they showed
things like collagen IgG - chain actin
they're able to look at all of these
things get a lot of information I'm
going to bring our resolution which
which could which means in a single
sample they're getting all these pieces
of information not having to do all the
different stains it's very interesting
as well and then there's the
particularly extinct you know a
continuation of those ambient pressure
ionization techniques where you're
looking at tissue this is in vivo
intraoperative mass spectrometry where
they do the iron ion lines and what you
can see here is they're taking the con
rising tool and the smoke that comes to
the cauterizing tool is capture in this
tube which is then piped back to the
mass spectrometer which you can see here
what that is is that as you may know in
microbiology they're able to do some
bacterial characterization based on the
the mass spectral patterns and they're
in applying a similar powder a similar
principle here where they're looking at
the patterns and differentiating between
the margins of a tumor the tumor and
healthy tissue outside of the tumor and
they're able to do this intraoperatively
in real time and again it's not this is
not widely and used yet but it is it
does show the potential of the
technology and what can be done this is
great work that's being done by zoltán
packets and at King's College ins it's
amazing so when we look at all these
things bring it together there's you
know probably three more full lectures
that we could that we can put together
here but I think if we if we pull away
from this but the thing that we really
know is that magnetometry has tremendous
potential potential for use in clinical
laboratories it's a flexible technology
but right now it's it's expensive and
it's low throughput you know it can be
applied both to clinical testing
clinical pathology and anatomic
pathology and it is compatible with lots
of different specimen types but it
really has to address the expense and
the throughput and I'm excited for the
future in mass spectrometry but
certainly I think some challenges have
to be met before it's widely used in
and medical laboratories and with that
I'll turn it over for any questions that
will be submitted
Thank You dr. Clark for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type in in the Q&A box sound like
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Clark will answer questions via
email I like to thank you dr. Clark for
joining us today
you have the final comments you'd like
to leave it on sure I'm just like to
thank you for attending the webinar
thank you to Agilent for sponsoring
educational content and I look forward
to getting questions and interacting
with you via email I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
submitting your questions via email we
would like to thank our educational
sponsor Agilent Technologies for today's
webcast the webcast can be viewed
on-demand through October 2017 lab rule
alert you via email when it is available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have not been able to watch today's
event we will see you next time here at
labyrinth comm goodbye
you